Okay.
So let's now get to the next piece of this
North Korea thing.
I told you a couple of weeks ago that Donald
Trump is increasingly taking foreign policy
advice from Fox News.
Propagandists Tucker Carlson making this really
the Fox News presidency.
I mean, Donald Trump's daily agenda is often
set by watching Fox News is a morning show.
Fox and friends, they'll talk about something
20 minutes later, Trump tweets about it, and
it's on the agenda for the day.
Or for a week.
If Trump has not much going on that week.
Trump regularly talks to Fox News, propagandists
Sean Hannity in the evenings and gets Hannity's
advice beforehand and he puts them to bed
and now Tucker Carlson has been added to the
mix.
It is truly the Fox News presidency.
Now, I will say it just so happens that some
of Tucker Carlson's influence on Trump might
be better than what Trump would be getting
from people formally in his administration,
if even for the wrong reason.
So like as an example, Tucker Carlson seems
to be against going into Iran.
That's good.
I'm also against going into Iran.
We don't want Donald Trump going into Iran.
We then learned that this weekend when Donald
Trump stepped into North Korea for the first
time by any sitting president to shake hands
with Kim Jong going on North Korean soil,
that it was Tucker Carlson rather than Donald
Trump's actual national security advisor.
John Bolton, who was with Donald Trump on
this trip.
Bolton instead was in Mongolia, not exactly
the center of the action over the weekend,
while Donald Trump was in North Korea with
Tucker Carlson, and of course concurrent with
this, Tucker Carlson is running propaganda
for Donald Trump's relationship with Kim Jong
Gun saying that to lead a country, you're
going to end up killing people in some way,
shape, or form.
Check out this cartoonish video.
Tucker Carlson calling in to Fox News,
Tucker.
Just one thing that you know that that's the
type of thing that does make some people nervous
though.
He recently, president Trump recently made
a comment about having a certain type of good
chemistry with Kim Jong [inaudible].
And that may be true, but when you're talking
about someone who has been responsible for
so many human rights abuses, does he run a
risk with that kind of language of a coming
off to Kim, Johnathan, like he's pandering
to him to an extent or be upsetting the American
public that that elected a president that
they want to stand firm and be tough on those
human rights violations and stand firm on
American principles, which exists in virtually
complete contrast to how the North Korean
regime is run.
Yeah, I mean there's no defending the North
Korean regime, which is a monstrous regime.
That's the last really Stalinist regime in
the world.
It's a disgusting place and obviously, and
so there's no defending it.
On the other hand, you know, you gotta be
honest about what it means to lead a country.
It means killing people, not on the scale
that the North Koreans do, but a lot of countries
committed atrocities, including a number that
were closely allied with.
So, you know, I'm not a relativist or anything,
but if it's important to be honest about that.
Now this may come as a shock to some people,
but Tucker Carlson is right to some degree
even about the killing stuff in a very particular
way.
Now I want to be really clear.
American presidents aren't killing people
in the way that North Korean leaders are killing
people.
But what Tucker Carlson is right about, and
it does not get discussed enough, is that
through the decisions of foreign policy that
American presidents make, people die as a
consequence.
And the question is how many, and for what
reason?
That being said, this is a completely ridiculous
way to defend Donald Trump who is being totally
bamboozled and con by Kim Jong Un period.
And that's really the problem here as I've
pointed out.
So understand what's going on as Tucker Carlson
is becoming Trump's sort of defacto national
security advisor over John Bolton, traveling
with him, giving him advice about Iran and
North Korea.
We have the choice of outrageous Warhawk warmonger
John Bolton or white nationalists, Tucker
Carlson, which is better.
I don't actually know.
I mean, I truly don't know.
At least recently on foreign policy, Tucker
does seem to be sort of providing Donald Trump
with a less bad point of view, which is stunning
to even be saying it's actually possible that
the world would be better off with Tucker
off Fox News PR, uh, where he spreads probable
a, a terrible propaganda and as a slightly
less war Hungary alternative to John Bolton,
his national security advisor.
I mean, that's hilarious to say.
It's also tragic to say that that might be
the case and in the meantime, remember that
the coziness between this administration and
Fox News continues to be completely disgusting.
It's effectively state and media at least
for the time being, and you only have to look
back at how Fox covered North Korea under
Obama versus how Fox covers North Korea under
Trump.
To understand the totally propagandistic nature
of this.
Look at this.
Would you as president meet with the leaders
of a country like North Korea?
Obama extraordinarily said bye.
I'd meet with him.
Senator Obama made his intentions crystal
clear on the campaign trail.
I will meet not just what our friends are.
What our enemy, President Obama likes talking
to dictators.
He would meet with some of these mad men without
any preconditions.
You know, I'm gonna reach out to these crazy
people around the world and try and get things
done.
So I think that's a mistake.
Or Obama is bowing and scraping before dictators.
What is Tim Obama doing?
Establishing formal contacts with these people,
how remarkable turnaround and relations between
two historic adversaries,
the commander and chief leadership is now
leading to a major foreign policy breakthrough.
Another stunning Donald Trump breakthrough.
So I could keep showing you more of the gushing
by Fox over Trump on North Korea, but you
probably understand it by now.
So these are, these are really strange dystopian
times that we're living in.
And I guess in a sense a Tucker Carlson is
a bigger and bigger part of those strange
times.
Let me know what you think.
Are we in a way better off with Tucker Carlson
giving Trump foreign policy ideas rather than
his completely war hungry, true national security
advisor, John Bolton.
I'm on Twitter at D Packman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Let me know what you think